we want to get right to our guest
joining me now dr robert redfield he is
director of the cdc and a real pleasure
to have you on the show sir so um
americans have pretty much made up their
mind about thanksgiving they've heard
the guidelines
you believe though that we need to
redouble our efforts in terms of
mitigation
how do you think we should do that if
people feel like they're already doing a
lot
well it's very important dana because
you know clearly right now you can see
the surge that we're seeing in new cases
unfortunately in hospitalizations and
and deaths and i just try to remind the
american public that we're not
defenseless against this we have
powerful tools that we now
know they work wearing masks
that works social distancing hand
washing being smart about crowds
really trying to be careful about what
we do in in
indoor settings these things really do
work and
they can really blunt this current surge
that we're having right now and
hope's on the way with the vaccine but
over the next
you know two four six eight ten twelve
weeks for many americans
we still need to really be vigilant
about these mitigation steps and stop
the debate
about whether they work or not there's
clear evidence that
for example that masks do work in
protecting individuals
from both becoming infected as well as
potentially infecting others could you
speak to
the status of the health care workers
the hospitalizations that we know are on
the rise
you know the just how bad is that
situation it's not bad everywhere but
you
you know you do see enough stories of
some hospitals having to
even think about rationing care yeah i
think this is the real challenge that we
have
you know and i do think we have to be
prepared i think
this issue of our health care system and
the resilience that it has
and i think in some areas we are going
to see the health care system
overwhelmed and this is why again the
vigilance
in the mitigation steps is so important
to keep those health care systems
from going over the top in terms of of
of being able to maintain their
resilience not just to serve people with
coven
but to serve people without cohen so i i
know that you are a big proponent of
following the science and the data and i
want to talk about schools in a moment
but i do want to ask you this so i read
in the new york times um
you know just that the available data
right now doesn't say that small
gatherings
are a big problem do you dispute that
yeah i think for us right now the
majority of transmission that we're
seeing
across the nation you know this is much
different than the fall
i mean the spring when we had several
metropolitan areas
now we really have a large portion of
the nation now that has
a transmission at the level of what we
call the
red zone and we're of the point of view
from the data that we have is that
that the real driver now of this
epidemic now is not the public square
it really is driven by the silent
epidemic the asymptomatic infections
largely in individuals
between the ages say 12 and 35. and then
when we come home to the safety of our
own setting
uh not wearing mass this is where the
inter-household transmission is
occurring and that's why
when you go look for a rural like you're
from wyoming
rural north dakota who would ever think
rural north dakota would be in the red
zone
it's all in the red zone it's really
being driven by a household okay so then
let me ask you i know that you
have said you just said last week at
that white house briefing that schools
you think
should and can stay open we know that
some of them are closing
what data point do they need or that you
could could you provide
to help them get a plan to get schools
to reopen and how soon could
parents see that i mean after the first
of the year
well i think it's important for each of
these jurisdictions
as i said to do this not based on
emotion but based on data
so each of these jurisdictions have data
in what's happened in their schools
since they've opened them and i can say
at a national level what we've seen
is that we've seen that really the k
through 12
schools have not been a source for
significant outbreaks or
significant acquisition when we've gone
into schools to evaluate
the kids that are infected or the
teachers infected it turns out
the teachers got infected from the
community from the maybe their spouses
and their families and not the kids
the student but not the kids and the
students didn't get infected in school
they got infected
from their household or their community
so really if you look at the data
and this is what i'm asking people to do
because each jurisdiction is going to
make this decision
look at your own data and see how well
has your school program work
that's the programs that i've seen
across the country
they've really worked remarkably well
many people that were negative about
opening schools now are saying
wait a minute we were able to do this
safely and responsibly and i think it's
an important lesson
for other industries that we want to
keep open figure out how to do it safely
and responsibly
and follow the data not the emotion that
oh we must we must close
the parents are very very frustrated and
i understand it's a
complicated decision but i think you're
right follow the data and see where you
go
there's good news on these vaccines um i
know that we're
a few weeks off before some people start
getting vaccinated but
how do you help decide and inform the
decision-making process as to
who gets the vaccine first that's going
to be the next
real difficult problem to try to
communicate to the public
yeah i think it's really important first
it's you know exceptional
that we have these vaccines and it's
very exciting and again it just
reinforces why i want people to be
vigilant
because we're turning the corner now you
don't want to be the last group to end
up getting coveted
because the vaccine is going to begin to
be rolled out uh probably by the end of
the second week of december
initially in a hierarchical way nursing
home residents
and then some combination of healthcare
providers and individuals at high risk
for a poor outcome and those decisions
are in the process of being finalized as
we speak
i do think we'll have about 40 million
doses of vaccine before the end of the
first year
of the year that's enough to vaccinate
20 million people but then
it will continue through january and
february and hopefully by march
we'll start to see vaccine available for
the general public we can ask you about
children because we talked about you
know some kids
we do know that they become infected and
they get sick but what is the latest on
the effects that covid if you if a kid
does get it and they
do have symptoms do we have any more
clarity as to how it affects them
well i will say first children obviously
do get infected
uh secondly they can infect others and
they're probably again a driver
of what i call the silent epidemic and
the transmission within households
um third it is correct that a majority
of uh
individuals under 17 if they do get
coveted really don't develop
symptoms and obviously the mortality in
that group is extremely extremely rare
you know looking at the long-term
consequences of covid
i don't think any of us can go out there
too far we're studying it trying to
understand it
uh clearly there's much more to cover
than just getting a respiratory illness
as we've seen
so but in general children uh
really are a group that are largely
spared from
the consequences of copenhagen and one
last question for you in the minute that
we have
i you know i read that no and i guess
this makes sense
um no pregnant women were a part of the
vaccine trials
what about that going forward how does
that work um
so that we can make sure that those moms
to be and their babies
are also safe yeah this is really
important uh
as you know and and and how to begin
that uh to get that safety data in the
setting of pregnancy
and i think you're going to see that
happen fairly rapidly
just like we're going to see studies
begin to look at
the safety and immunogenicity in in
children too
so those are priorities uh obviously
it's pretty
normal that we bring new products into
humans we really do
spare pregnant women initially uh but i
can tell you uh
that they're gonna be um targeted to
show safety
and efficacy in that group very rapidly
well we appreciate you taking all of
these questions i could talk to you for
the entire hour but i know you're a busy
man you've got a lot to do and happy
thanksgiving to you dr robert redfield
thank you
thank you very much dana